joining me on the phone now i was joking
before actually i wasn't joking
it's not a joke that years ago after
working with this guy
at nfl network i said you know what kara
henderson and i said
world's greatest human and charles davis
from cbs is now getting ready to call
charles how many super bowls will this
be for you
hey andrew this will be eight
eight that is awesome yes my eighth yeah
how fortunate am i and charles uh you
you for those who don't know charles
lives in florida so this is kind of a
local game for you here
before we actually get to the game could
you
try to paint the picture what tampa is
like this year
being different than all other super
bowl cities in the middle of a pandemic
well you know the super bowl's going on
you can tell that that part's easy
you know your signage is everywhere cars
are going by with the buck stuff
all the stores have the go bucks and
super bowl 55
and people are very excited about it but
you don't have the throngs
that's what's different you know people
would have poured into the city by now
already and you you would recognize it
everywhere
you know if you go to get something to
eat right you go you go to
grab a coffee just walking down the
street somewhere
you know where we've done the shows is a
wonderful place called
uh i believe it's called armature works
and it's set
right off the water in tampa and this
nice little great area which is
perfectly conducive to
a lot of crowds watching the shows and
what have you and you know andrew from
past experience at super bowl
heck on a thursday night game right if
you do something in the afternoon or
whatever you attract
people and it's just not the numbers
and that is a co that's part of covet
you know people can't be out in crowds
and
next to each other and i know florida's
a little more wide open than a lot of
places because i live in the state
but that doesn't still make it where
everybody's like yeah let's go hang out
you know it's just not the same and you
don't have the visitors coming in
at the same rate charles i think we're
talking to charles davis here from cbs
who is in tampa calling the game on the
international feed here coming up on
sunday super bowl 55 charles's eighth
super bowl i i think and you know this
from being out
in stadiums every week and talking to
teams virtually every week leading up to
games teams are used to this by now this
is the world we've lived in teams have
adjusted
this is not in any way different but i
tell me if i'm nuts i do think that the
chiefs benefit this week
by flying in on saturday and not being
there regardless of how dialed back the
throngs of humanity are
i think am i wrong to think that they
can
benefit from staying at home all week i
i
i'm with you on that one that's been one
of the great questions all week and
i don't know that we'll have a
definitive answer when the game's over
andrew it's just
you know where it's all theory isn't it
how does it work best
it's kind of like an analogy would be
for the longest time when you went to
play in denver remember when we were
kids
everybody talked about how you had to
get there earlier in the week and
acclimate your team
right so teams would leave really early
in the week and then
you found out from sports scientists
they said hold on a second
the worst of it actually occurs after
three or four days
because it takes longer than that to
acclimate the best thing you can do is
go as late as possible
and i remember there was an afc
championship game and i think your
beloved cleveland browns
may have asked the league if they could
come in late the evening because they
were supposed to be there by a certain
time it would have been 89
if that were the case yeah i think it
was them but don't hold me to it
but somebody for really important game
asked the league if they could come in
later and i think believe it was granted
and i think the the broncos flipped out
like whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
they're supposed to be in by this time
because they were hoping some more of
those
altitude effects would take place my
point is very simply this
this year if kansas city had had to come
and be in tampa for an entire week it's
not the hotels at all
it's just the atmosphere the atmosphere
is this is a damp a buccaneers home game
i mean and the buffs would have been in
their own beds and
all those other things it to me it would
have been a major disadvantage but this
one
a normal business trip oh yeah and how
many games in a row now have the
chiefs one with patrick mahomes as their
quarterback
either road or neutral we're in double
digits i think it's 12 straight
so them i'm with you on this one this
one to me benefits kansas city
the only thing that's changed for them
this week is they've had to do more zoom
media obligations sure everything else
own beds own practice field
everything like that i think it's a huge
advantage that advantage
but a huge release yeah for kansas city
since they're playing tampa bay
if it's playing someone else then then
you know
it's all neutral right yeah everybody's
doing the same thing anyway but this is
different because tampa is the home team
and truly the home team yeah and and
the the virtual commitments are still
there and they're massive this week
but you can do them from home or you
could do them from the facility or you
could do them
in your car if someone else is driving
for pete's sake when you are there
brady did yeah tom brady did his getting
treatment
right when you're there you know
if you're one of the big name players
hey guess what the
the car service is picking you up
tuesday night at six o'clock you got to
be downstairs and they got to get you
across town
to get to this appearance you're doing
and then you got to sign a couple
autographs it's a meet and greet and
then you're going back and
and you're trying to juggle all those
not everyone has those but none
of those for lack of a better word
distractions are there
and sometimes for a second year super
bowl team a team that has done that you
you would have learned to cut them out
anyway
like we came last year we had a good
time we've gone through this we're the
veterans now
and maybe it wouldn't have been that bad
but just being able to be
at home and get up like it's any other
game
saturday morning get to the facility do
your covet test do your tsa get on the
bus
fly there check in do your meetings as
normal
nothing's different except just a bunch
of interviews during the week
talking to the great charles davis yeah
for those i would agree great point
great point on that andrew and i'm just
going to cap it with this
yep what we're seeing with this super
bowl and how we are having to cover it
it'll be interesting when we have this
conversation when we get back to what we
keep calling
a normal world now we know nothing will
be normal again
but let's say we're back to where you
move around freely
you know we're not having to wear masks
right we can have throngs again
how many different things we're adding
this year are doing this year
will we retain and how we cover next
year
because i do think if we get it back
media night on monday night
i think it'll come back because it was
such a happening
but the rest of the stuff during the
week where they have to go to the podium
and if
that may change in the zoom stuff may
stay
in order to take a lot of the burden off
the players as you just talked about
charles it's a great point and it's
something that roger goodell
in his state of the league address
yesterday was asked about and the one
thing that he said not not specifically
about you know super bowl weak stuff
necessarily
but just you know broad broad strokes he
said
virtual isn't going away i think
next year no one thinks the world is
going back to normal by kickoff 2021
but hopefully we're part of the way
there right hopefully there is
progress it's not entirely like it is
right now
and so then you're kind of caught in the
middle you you you
keep some of the stuff you implemented
this year you kind of open things up a
little bit just like the real world
and it might be two or three years till
the real world gets back to being the
real world and that and that goes for
the nfl
as well and then as you adapt what do
you
actually keep i want i want to ask you
about the quarterbacks here because as a
former defensive back
right you know you can't you can't be
looking to the backfield here
right you can't can't have your eyes in
the backfield
is that different though when you have a
guy
like patrick mahomes where so much stuff
is off schedule
yeah and that's what you know we talk we
talk in so many
buzz phrases right you know the the cool
phrase
that pops up remember when a quarterback
could throw the ball really well
and now we say he has arm talent right
you can tell me i'm nuts by the way you
you can tell me i'm just using jargon if
you want
nuts you're not nuts but where i'm going
with that
is we the the the phrase that is really
in vogue and has been over the past few
seasons
is what you want to get their eyes in
the wrong place
right that's what you want to do with
defenders and
we used to call it faking them out now
we want their eyes we want their eyes
wrong okay cool whatever you want
it's like a george carlin bit right here
i love it right but as
a defensive back you your training has
always been when things
break down your eyes don't go to the
quarterback they go to where the
receivers are
and so now of course we don't just go
cover the receiver
you plaster to the receiver and that's
where the key is with a guy like that
because when he's moving around
he put you in a situation where
especially those underneath coverage
guys
make a decision hey i'm gonna go tackle
my homes and leave an area
flick kelsey grabs and goes 30 yards or
whoever it is
that's what they're talking about that's
what you're worried about as a defensive
back
with tom brady he's not going to run
around and scare you
but they've been talking this weekend at
such a great point that in the past rush
his ability to evade and shoulder shrug
and step
up or step sideways and find an open
space
and then set his feet and make a big
time throw it's second to none
i mean frank clark was talking about it
chris jones was talking about
the password for kansas city chris jones
has no sacks in the playoffs
so far so he's more than due and he was
lamenting that he thought he had tom
brady
in a playoff game and he gave him that
shoulder shrug and missed
and he said i still don't know how i'm
doing he said frank clark said yesterday
he's got great shoulders like
to charles's point i've never heard a
defender go that quarterback's got great
shoulders
but that call comes out of the drill
work in the off season
and and you'll see it you know you'll
see it in this game from both of them
when the pass rush comes and they feel
it coming to either side or
both sides watch how they make sure they
turn their body
to where you know the back foot and the
front foot and you're really sideways
and they'll do that shoulder shimmy
thing and kind of pull themselves
through the pass rush
and either step up or step to the side
trying to find that open spaces those
small little movements
that create big plays downfield it's not
necessarily taking off and
and getting to the perimeter and doing
the boogaloo
it's a lot more of those small depth
slide steps
and brady's the master of those charles
one last thing before we let you go and
i appreciate your time you have a game
i'm told coming up on sunday you
probably have some prep to do and so
we greatly appreciate it was listening
to frank reich and philip
rivers a couple of months ago and they
both said how
they on monday go back and watch the tv
copy
so the on air broadcast and and they
listen
for what was picked up on the tv mics
because this year everything's picked up
with no fans in the stands
and that they have to go through and
change things more so than they have
in any other season obviously
considering these two teams played each
other
and considering there there is a
season's worth of film
now how radically do you think in these
two weeks
that these two teams have had to rewrite
their line calls their checks everything
probably not as radically as we might
think because i think both of them have
seasoned head coaches
they're going to make sure that you
don't overthink it
and and overburden people with change
but there will be yeah there will be
some changes along the way
similar to baseball signals you can keep
the exact same signals right
you just change the indicator when the
signal's on and when it's off right
that's kind of what i think these teams
are going to try and do
to maybe hey we we used this last time
give it to them right out of the gate
and see if they tumble too right see if
they bite we know that we're going to
something else
right you know what i mean mm-hmm see if
they don't overthink it yeah just don't
just don't all of a sudden hey we're
changing everything guys now they're
standing there thinking
and not playing and i think that's bad
for both teams i think with these two
coaches that
there's no danger of that happening and
uh while you're at it if you're kansas
city be sure to walk around the stadium
and make sure there's no one there
banging a trash can if you're going to
bring baseball into it charles let's
make sure there's no
banging of trash cans on the concourse
here
to help out the home waving or waving
the towel from center field or waving
the tower
make sure there's no one on the pirate
ship in any way raising a flag
to somehow indicate anything is coming
from the chiefs the great charles davis
from cbs so you could hear on the
international call
uh it is great to have you on sir great
to connect as always
have a great game on sunday
thanks a lot always great to connect
with you sorry i missed you last week at
mobile
but we will reunite there next year we
missed you
and don't worry we you didn't miss the
bacon donuts on sunday morning there
were none because okovid the bacon
no bacon donuts next year next year
next year in mobile which i believe is
in the old testament thank you charles
thank you sir be good likewise hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that
watch more right here